yes
chairman okay
good evening members welcome to rockford
district council's remote meeting of the
executive
uh welcome to uh all members and
non-members of the executive attending
in person
through this virtual meeting and also to
anyone
watching this via the live stream
just before we get into the meeting i
would just like us to take a few moments
to
remember so captain uh
captain sir tom moore um rocha district
council lowered its flags today
that the civic suite in rainey to half
mast
is a mark of respect following the sad
passing of captain sir tom
moore the chairman of rochford district
council
councillor robin dre said i was saddened
to hear
of the passing of captain sir thomas
moore yesterday
this very courageous man was the
inspiration we all needed
during the time of grave national crisis
he showed us that anyone no matter what
your age or circumstances
and always have the potential to make a
huge
difference i'm glad
that here in the rockford district we
can acknowledge his accomplishments
and honor his memory in this way if we
can just take a few moments please just
to reflect
on his memory and his great achievement
thank you members moving to agenda item
one apologies for absence and
i think we're all here no apologies
needed
moving to item two uh
sonia would you be kind enough to read
out the names of any non-members
attending please
certainly chairman um we we have in
attendance
uh councillors sparing
hoy newport gooding
and mrs mason
public members of the executive
attending
the most most welcome today and
moving on to agenda item number three
are the minutes of the meeting held on
the second of december are grade members
agreed chairman great great chairman
agreed thank you very much i will thank
those who have
agreed i don't see anyone signifying
otherwise
right the gender item number four
sorry did someone right moving to agenda
item number four
are there any declarations of interest
anyone wishes to
make please
again i can't see any raised hand icons
or anyone signifying
council williams did i see anything from
you
no okay bye um
right moving on to agenda item number
five
uh questions on notice from councillors
no questions have been received for
this meeting which takes us nicely onto
agenda item six matters referred to the
executive
reports from other committees and there
are none
members agenda item
7 the connect program
update the assistant director
transformation and customers
dawn tribe deputy leader councillor
cheryl rowe and angela hogg
connect program project manager will
provide a verbal
update on progress with the connect
cultural
and transformation program
thank you chairman um i thought it would
take this opportunity to provide a
connect culture and transformation
program update
that was following the agreement
executive on the 8th of july
to bring forward the appointment of the
transformation program manager
from phase two to phase one of the
program
and i am pleased to say that that
appointment has happened and angela hogg
is with us tonight
moving forward updates will be reported
quarterly as part of the program
management office
report the bringing forward of this
appointment
was in a direct response to the changes
in the way we were working due to covid
19 pandemic these changes primarily
being staff working from home
but with services relying on workarounds
for delivering
for delivery models which were being
used pre-covered 19 which are not really
sustainable
the staff have adapted really well to
working more flexibly and agile
but now is the opportunity for us to
look at those things that we said we
would do under the connect
program to bring those forwards to to
enable our customers to work
through digital channels and improving
the
customer experience so there is an
opportunity
to identify and to implement these
changes
earlier than we first did expect and
it's interesting
actually looking at the feedback from
the budget survey
which shows um when the question was
asked about the council modernizing
uh modernizing their services and
increasing the use of modern technology
these actually scored very highly in in
that
feedback if i may chairman
i would like to hand over to councillor
cheryl rowe who would like to say a few
words
thank you thank you
and big welcome to angela my internet's
gone down
it has no it doesn't it doesn't appear
to you we're receiving you loud and
clear
wow that's fine good thank you the
screen just went down sorry
everyone yes big welcome to angela it's
great to see you here tonight
i'm delighted to be able to provide you
with an update on the council's connect
connect
cultural and transformation change
program there's been a considerable
activity and progress made in the last
few months
and the pace at which the program is
moving is a credit to the leadership
team
work stream leads and key change
champions
particularly in these most challenging
challenging of times
as we know it will be through the
connect program that the council will be
able to deliver the best
customer experience possible
underpinned by the creation of a more
empowered and agile workforce
every single officer and elected member
of the council has an important part to
play
in achieving the the required
transformation
and services and cultural change i would
also like to highlight the immensely
important work that nikki and more has
been leading on as connect
workforce development work stream lead
supporting our offices has never been
so crucial a wide ranging of ongoing
staff development program
will provide the necessary training and
tools to equip our officers
and to continue to deliver services to
our customers
as well as a focus on their well-being
and ability
for many to adopt new ways of working in
different working environment
we have commissioned the services of
angela hogg
via east of england local government
association to lead on the program
management of connect
i am pleased to be able to now hand over
to angela to talk you through the pro
progress made to date and the tools in
place that give us confidence
the key objectives and benefits of
connect will be delivered against the
agreed project plan
thank you angela over to you
thank you councillor um and thank you
everyone for inviting me to meet with
you this evening
um i'm really delighted as the connect
program manager
to be sharing this transformational
journey with you
and to have the opportunity to outline
the really great progress
already made with the connect program
um i'd like to now move to a fairly
short presentation
uh to guide us through my update if
that's okay so i'm gonna
share my screen
is everyone okay to see that yeah
thank you thank you uh so
as i've already been alluded to i'd
firstly like to highlight that the great
effort that has been made to date by the
leadership team
and councillor as project member sponsor
um as the connect program manager my
function has got many different aspects
around ensuring the delivery of the
council's gold project
although this evening i would really
like to concentrate on two particular
elements
so firstly is around explaining the
program the project
framework and the controls that are in
place to give you the confidence that
connect is on track to deliver
the required transformation and benefits
to the customer
and the council and also to bring you up
to date with connect
the next steps and the governance
arrangements
so just by way of a quick uh reminder
the connect is obviously a gold uh
project for the council
approved and supported by members which
is crucial
so there are four work streams service
delivery
led by dawn tribe uh and the next
important phase of this work has just
commenced
uh with key change champions in the
development of invest to save
projects the communication and
engagement work
extreme lead led by louisa moss
obviously this
this aspect is key in engaging with
staff and stakeholders
about the connect program the workforce
development
led by nikki and moore is also
critical in ensuring that staff have the
knowledge tools and skills to support
transformation and uh nikki will
separately update you
on this aspect and the final work stream
is around the asset delivery programme
led by matt harwood wood wright and
that's that whole area has now been
incorporated within the connect program
in terms of monitoring and reporting so
these all four now under the umbrella
of the connect program
so if we look at the significant
progress made today and just going back
really to last july when i was
appointed as the connect program manager
lots of activity and work has been done
in the background so i'm really really
pleased
today to be able to come and speak to
you about
all the work that has already been
undertaken and what's now
the next focus on what we have to do so
working with the leadership team we've
had an opportunity really to revisit
connect
as a result result of the pandemic and
in terms
of the agile working we've learned
lessons from this
uh with a significant shift shift to a
staff working from home
and we appreciate that connect is so
much more than this
and this experience has really helped us
shape connect going forward
in terms of digital transformation it's
even now
more important as we've heard from dawn
customers needs have changed and it's
really important
that we continue to be flexible and
improve that customer experience through
digital
transformation and in terms of customer
needs connect will also
change the way that we work and again
this all feeds into enhancing that
customer experience
and aligned with the digital
transformation and changes in ways of
working
and supporting staff's well-being the
staff development program
has been um it is being progressed
so in terms of moving forward and to
create a really strong foundation
in terms of to be able to push forward
with connect we have a number of
different aspects in place already
so we have all different tools uh
there's a project plan excuse me risks
and issue register
we do regular highlight reporting and
there's various templates and guidance
to be able to assist
officers to be able to be part of this
journey with us with minimizing
resourcing as much as possible
so in terms of uh next steps really
the monumental effort that we've already
described will now continue to be led
uh primarily by the council's key change
champions
and we've had a first meeting with them
at the end of january to really focus
on the next phase so the key change
champions are
obviously managers within the council
and that they're a group of managers
that work together across services
that will develop ideas into proposals
and then in turn to invest to save
business cases
places for approval it's really
important
to note that the key change champions
will lead on this work in addition to
their normal role
as service manager leads
looking forward in terms of that
pipeline of proposals
the investors say business cases we will
be looking to present this to
executive committee in your july meeting
it's worth noting at this stage it's
very difficult to anticipate the number
of business cases that may actually be
put forward to exec at this point
as this would depend on the amount of
viable proposals created
and generated by the key change
champions
the leadership team will prioritize and
look to group proposals where there is
synergy
as a minimum a pipeline of business
cases will be presented
business cases will be prioritized based
on those with the greatest
and quickest benefits before going to
exec
business cases will be reviewed by the
connect
programme board and my role will be
really critical to ensure that only
those business cases that have been
thoroughly looked at
through the agreed process and
demonstrate that are both robust and
viable i'll put forward
to exec at that stage we will however
look to implement any viable proposals
as early as possible via the connect
programme board
in other words quick wins where there is
an obvious benefit
and no investment required
so in terms of governments just look at
the kind of key groups
we have a connect project group that
meets every two weeks
and that reports progress via monthly
connect highlight reporting
and every quarter that feeds into the
connect
program board
then every quarter it will feed into the
leadership
team business review meeting and in turn
via the project management office to
exec
and just to really summarize on some of
the key points um
you know even with all the difficulties
presented by the kind of apparent
pandemic
and significant impact on resources
ratchford is well placed to achieve the
objectives of connect
both in terms of its digital
transformation and changes to ways of
working
and improving the customer experience
as an approved gold project connect has
your
support and this is both valued and
crucial
your leadership team is committed to the
success of connect
and supports key change champions and
services
to lead on this change
a range of strong project management
tools are now in place
to give you the confidence on the
delivery of the benefits that you seek
and through nikki's work in the staff
development program
staff will be supported both in terms of
their skillset
and well-being thank you for your time
i'll
hand back to dawn
thank you angela um
as um angela just mentioned about the
workforce development
nikki is here and we'll um give a brief
update
where she is with the workforce
development if that's okay tim
it is over to you nikki good evening
members
um as uh angela said i'm the workforce
development lead for connect
it's a really important work stream and
quite rightly has a dedicated focus
the council's ambitious plans for
transformation need to be fully
supported by the officers
analysis of the training and development
needs of the officers has started
and is ongoing and this will inform the
design of the staff development
programme
already we've identified through a
digital skills audit
some need for digital training but also
some softer skills such as people
management
and building resilience our staff
are our biggest asset is often said in
organizations
and it's never been truer than it is now
at rochford
the staff development programme will
ensure an investment
in this key asset so that residents can
ultimately
have the best customer experience
i've also been working on some key
documents such as a connect people plan
and an agile working policy and also on
a refreshed appraisal system
to manage staff performance in the new
ways of working
i'm looking forward to sharing more
information and detail with members as
we move forward
with this work stream thank you
thank you nikki um and are there any
questions
thank you just before we take any any
questions uh
can i just say that to be
involved with this ambitious program it
would have been very easy this time last
year to actually put it in cold storage
and say well we've got enough of a
challenge
uh in dealing with the issues to do with
the current crisis
but no you've carried on everything is
running
uh to time there could have been no
better test
than to pass out home working to all the
staff
that have adapted to it in a wonderful
way but actually it was a dress
rehearsal for
the real thing to test people's ability
to
do remote working and i think it is a
real tribute that
uh as a team you've pushed on with this
project
along with all the other additional
things that kobe has thrown at us
as well as dealing with business as
usual so my personal thanks
for this tremendous piece of work which
is essential
to the future success as we derive
benefits from
transformation and what technology and
agile working can
offer so that's my personal appreciation
on behalf of
all of the executive thank you very much
indeed if i can
take a question from councillor fd
thank you chairman um just one question
really
talked a lot about staff taking staff
with this with connect
we need to be taking members as well we
need to members need to learn answering
how to interact with the new buildings
and
how to interact with how connect's going
to work
going into the future i know we talk
about
uh key change champions is there a fault
of a members remember key change
champion at all
um we haven't we haven't thought of a
members
champions at the moment but certainly as
far as the um
digital and uh protect new technology
it's something i have spoken to um sonia
about
the training sub group and talking about
how that training for
members and we can develop members
knowledge of technology
um it's not that's not just around how
we use the laptops
but it's about the implementing of our
things like our customer relationship
management system with our single
sign-on customer portal
and so um through the subgroup we're
going to look at how we can provide some
training but also
maybe do some of informal sessions with
members around the implementation
of that new technology to the to the
customers so that
we're bringing everybody on board it's
quite um
early days with the key change champions
at the moment
um and we're looking really quite
quickly and looking at those
projects the investor saved projects
then after that once
we've decided what they will be we would
then know what projects were moving
forward
and then we would then know um the
training needs or uh
where there's gap in training needs both
for members and for staff
brilliant thank you don thank you
councillor belton you wish to ask a
question
thank you and firstly just to say
if the last year's showing us anything
it's the importance of being adaptable
and how vital technology is to to
business and community alike
so i'm excited and welcome this new
versatile and robust way of working for
the council
and i was just curious um you mentioned
sort of
having reviewed things as a result of
the pandemic and has it changed much
from the original plan has the pandemic
changed the original vision or actually
has it sort of played into its hands if
you like by its very nature of sort of
the home working
um it's it's played into the hands of
what we wanted to do with with the
connect
transformation um program um
there was a cult big cultural piece that
we thought we were going to need to do
um that cultural piece of of getting our
staff to work in an agile flexible way
was obviously put upon us
very quickly and and i must say it's
been incredible not just staff actually
members as well
yourselves in the way that everybody has
adapted
to that agile flexible working so that
piece of the
the cultural piece of working and people
adapting to that is put upon us
that's not to say that this is this is
perfect way of doing things
because we do understand we are still in
a pandemic
and there is still work that people need
to do within the offices
um and so that that proves proves
difficult in itself at the moment
but the opportunities are there now to
really look at how we can enhance what
we're doing
um and so the well-being of staff and
and nikki are more working
on the workforce development stuff to
actually support staff and bringing
those things forward now
is really really crucial thank you
thank you councillor
thank you chairman um for those of you
who had listened to my speech i did
actually say
that every elected member of this
council has an important part to play
and i can only emphasize that every
member of this
council has an important part to play
as well as our members of staff thank
you chairman
thank you i can't see anyone else
indicating
so i'd just like to repeat my thanks on
behalf of the executive for attendance
tonight
and uh providing that very useful
briefing
and we wish you every success as you
progress through the
program thank you very much indeed
moving on to agenda item number eight
which is the quarter three 20 20 21
financial management report i'm going to
ask the portfolio holder for financial
services councillor simon smith
to present the report i'm sure that he
will be ably assisted
by uh assistant director naomi lucas
thank you simon
thank you chairman uh quarter three is
particularly
important because as we get to toward
the end of year things tend to get a bit
clouded by
the budget and i i dare say elections
and the end of year is subject to a lot
of formal processes that take some time
so quarter three is a particularly
important staging post
the purpose of this report is to set out
the forecast revenue
and capital budget positions as at
quarter three
the forecast outrun at quarter three is
a projected underspend
of 154 000 pounds
given the ongoing pressures we hope that
by the time we get to the end of the
year we will be in a balanced position
which represents a great achievement
the projected underspend is due to
prudent financial management
which combined with the full application
of the council's 2020-2021
covert grant allocation of 1.1 million
pounds
has allowed the council to contain its
covert 19 related pressures
this year the council is incurring
additional covert 19 related expenditure
in a number of areas
such as support for our leisure services
provision for homeless services
increased litter collection and it's
also and we're also
expected to face losses across a number
of income lines
most notably of which is car parking
the council is required to report
monthly on its expected financial
pressures
relating to the pandemic and these
returns have been shared with members
central government has introduced a
scheme to reimburse local authorities
for an element of its lost income
an initial claim for 458 000 pounds has
been made
and a final window for claims in this
financial year
when we opened at year end the covid 19
pandemic
is continued to have an impact expected
to have an impact
into 21 22 although the full impact
cannot yet be clear it will depend on
how quickly the wide recur
economy recovers the government has
confirmed that the income compensation
scheme
will continue at least into the first
quarter of
2021 22. it's also announced
unring-fenced covert grant for local
authorities in the next financial year
and for rochford the allocation is
341 000 pounds
the position will continue to be closely
monitored for the remainder of the year
and beyond as expected the original
capital
program for 2020 and 21 was reprofiled
earlier in the year
and the revised budget is now 1.969
million
the forecast outrun on the council's
capital programme
as a quarter 3 is 1.590
million the table in appendix 3
summarizes the projected position by
service area
it can't go without know chairman that
the amount of
flux change and the dynamic nature of
the year has made this year
exceptionally challenging to say the
least
i'll recommend to you the decision
printed on
1.1 to note the report are happy to take
questions with the assistance of naomi
who i must again thank for all her hard
work
and the many hours of work that have
gone into this report
under the further management of our
financial affairs
during this very very challenging year
thank you
thank you councillor smith uh any
questions
that you wish to ask of councillor smith
i can't see any
blue hands coming up
i can't see any indications whatsoever
so you got away with that one extremely
well
thank you chairman um and can i
also on behalf of the executive just uh
endorse your comments
so both yourself as portfolio holder
under your
stewardship of the financial management
along
very ably supported by the assistant
director naomi
lucas and her team uh for the brilliant
work that has gone on in a
unimaginable year in terms of managing
this council's finances and i really
cannot stress
the brilliant work that has been carried
out by that team
uh in terms of the additional work
and dealing with uh the distribution of
a huge
sum of money to ensure that our
businesses are supported
in line with the parameters set out
under the government scheme
it's a real tribute to everyone and
a bit like the transformation program
it's above and beyond
business as usual we need to remember
that thank you very much indeed
now if i move to uh paragraph 1.1
there is one recommendation and that's a
recommendation to note so i read out
uh it is the note quarter 3 20 20 21
revenue budget
and capital positions set out in
sections three and four
and detailed at appendices one to four
is that noted members noted
noted noted
noted thank you members
moving on to agenda item nine
the waste collection and street
cleansing contract
the portfolio holder for environment and
place
counselor arthur williams will introduce
the report
councillor williams thank you chairman
and members thank you very much i'd like
to introduce the report that you have
before you regarding our waste
collection and street cleansing contract
also associated exempt appendices to
this
to this report my sincere thanks go to
the members of the working group for
all of their hard work which is so very
much appreciated
i have to say this was the most
informative task i am sure
well i hope anyway that they agree with
that
as you all know as a council we have an
excellent record for our waste
management and recycling
this has been at the forefront of our
minds whilst making these
recommendations to council
with this in mind we now have the
opportunity opportunity to improve this
still further
i would also at the moment like to take
this opportunity to thank all of our
staff and contractors for maintaining
such high standards
during this very difficult time nothing
short of fantastic
thank you all fantastic job thank you
also my thanks to officers especially um
a.d marcus hotten for such a concise
detailed report whom i'm sure we'll be
able to answer any questions that we may
have
over to you marcus thank you
uh thank you council williams can you
can you hear me clearly
excellent so i'm just trying a new a new
head piece it's to try and cut
out some of the uh background noise of
the children it sounds like a locker
room in a rugby club
next door a lot of the time so it's an
attempt to try and uh
soften the blow of the noise um well
thank you members um the report sets out
um there are a proposed approach to
procuring the new waste collection
um and street cleansing contracts which
is due to commence in 2022
there are five recommendations that as
members you are being asked to consider
and what i'm posing to do is to go
through uh the recommendations briefly
um uh summarizing drawing to your
attention and relevant parts of the
report
that sort of uh flesh out each
recommendation
um so if i take its recommendation in
term uh recommendation 1.1
is basically to agree a three-month
extension to existing contracts
uh the report itself sets out the
reasons for for doing so
uh in paragraphs 5.12 to 5.20
but specifically if i can draw attention
to exempt appendix one
this sets out the timetable um the
contracts award
is planned for september 2021
and to do this this would require the
contract to mobilize in six months
before the existing contract
ceases in march 2022
and although achievable a nine-month
mobilization period
would be a far more attractive to the
market and allow greater contingency
should it be required
and this is one of the key things you'll
find throughout the
uh this report and in how we've
developed these contracts is that
we're trying to ensure that the uh
tender that we put
out is attractive to the market as
possible and therefore we have as many
bidders as possible
uh which should then drive the price
down it's about making sure that there
is
real competition and interest for these
contracts so it's not about being soft
so you'll hear me mention this
again and again through the report about
it being attracted to the market and
things it's not about us rolling over to
the market
it's about ensuring that we are aligned
with what the market
um feels it is able to bid for and so in
to do this and we're going to provide a
longer mobilization period of nine
months
uh and he's proposed his pen it's
proposed um
pending uh executive approval uh that a
three-month extension to existing
contracts
uh reflects the current price and terms
and conditions be finalized with sues
and so at a time it
finishes in march 22 we're suggesting it
then finishes in july
2022 but essentially it is the same
contract as we have now in terms of
price in terms of conditions
it's just simply a three month extension
but this allows us
a greater mobilization period time
although not essential i would argue
will appeal
heavily to the market um with regards to
recommendation
1.2 the approval of the 20 000 pound
budget
for legal services and recommendation
1.4
which refers to the tender process i
would take those both together
and i'd like to draw members attention
to section 5 page 9.2 of the report
which sets out the proposals for
procurement and the use of the
competitive procedure
with negotiation uh this will give
potential bidders certainty over
investing in time
put together a bid with the vast
majority of the core contracts specified
therefore
they clear out what they're costing
against um but we'll still allow degree
of negotiation
on certain aspects of the contracts uh
for example the provision of commercial
waste services
so the key points negotiation are listed
under section seven
starting at paragraph 7.14 and the key
points are
provision of capital ict arrangements
national waste strategy commercial waste
service
and charging for garden waste collection
and these are points that we bring back
back to uh to consider and discuss with
each contractor to see
um what proposals they have and would
allow us to actually shape
the final um version of the tender
specification
so this process negotiation required
input from a
legal expertise of a commercial
background to provide advice in the
negotiations and help finalize the
contract
so it's proposed that twenty thousand
pound budget is approved by the
executives to provide this legal support
as part of this procurement process
members have also been asked to
specifically note the 60 price and 40
quality evaluation and further note the
evaluation process criteria
has set out and exempts appendix 2.
the rationale for the 60 40 split is set
out in the report paragraph 5.8 to 5.10
uh and in summary the waiting was chosen
to ensure the value for money we've
achieved
but recognizes that quality will also be
given considerable waiting
in a service that reaches every
household in the districts
this weighting also agrees with the
recommendation by ricardo
for uh similar waste services contracts
that have been successful
in recent last couple of years in terms
of of
a walled with regard to uh
recommendation 1.3
key terms of the contracts i'm asking
members to note section 7 of this report
which sets out key aspects of contract
specification
the significant change in comparison to
existing contracts is it reflects the
aims of the
roger's new waste strategy as agreed by
council um the key passes is really
though
it's gonna be the removal of the um
weekly
combined food and garden waste service
replacing
with a um alternate weekly section of
garden waste and a weekly collection of
food and that is
what the waste strategy identified and
the contract reflects
that that critical change putting aside
that change
um fundamentally the collection service
in terms of recycling collection
refuse collection um collections to
flats
bin returns the city selections etc the
rest of the contracts
will basically remain the same as it is
essentially a good service i think
you'll agree
that that uh you know over over the sort
of period that i've been involved
it works i think we click we're keen to
say
um the final recommendation a 1.5
is not the inclusion of street cleansing
contract within the waste collection
service
um for a previous reports executive um
options were scoped out to to look at
the delivery of the street cleansing
contracts
the reports identified further work
should be undertaken by consultant
provide cost adoptions
these options were a standalone street
cleansing contract
street cleansing incorporated into the
green green gateway
trading uh blacco
combining the street cleansing and waste
collection service very much as we do
now
and and the fourth option was
incorporating litter collection
of the grounds maintenance contracts
into any one of the above options
so essentially it's a little bit of
litter picking that's selling open
spaces and the bins are emptied now buy
grounds maintenance could actually be
picked up by the street cleansing
contracts instead
um the consultant report which is
appended which is an exempt appendix
in appendix 4 has summarized the
continuation of combined street
cleansing
and weight effection service
incorporating that extra litter
collection
from the grounds maintenance contracts
would achieve the lowest contract price
so the saving itself was around about 35
000
pounds a year which uh given the
contract prices around about eight
hundred
eight hundred thousand a year you could
argue is is a fact packet
in many ways it's not something that
would
necessarily typically one way or the
other but i would argue that um
firstly um we have an effective service
already
and therefore there's no savings as such
to be achieved you'll be changing for
change's sake
if you chose a different option i think
critically as well the soft marketing
and
further intelligence from ricardo
suggested incorporating the street
cleansing into the waste collection
service as we do now
makes this a significantly more
attractive contract to the market
and so in a sense that that covers uh
all five points of the contracts of the
reports and i'm happy to take questions
thank you thank you marcus uh and
there's a number of blue hands so i go
first of all to councillor hefty
thank you marcus for a really well put
together a report
um i just got a question on 7.21
and where is it can i just can i just
stop you
there counselor i'm sorry to interrupt
you but i ought to remind the members
that there are a number of exempt
appendices to the report
if you need to make any reference for
any of these or wish to speak or ask
questions on any of these
can you please indicate before speaking
as it will be necessary to move
a recommendation to exclude the present
public first
so i should have given you that as a
preliminary warning not to stray into
the exempt
part unless of course you wish to and in
that case we would have to uh
move into uh quite a bit the
confidential session
uh sorry for fbi it's not an exempt i
don't think is it
i don't think it is seven point yeah 7.2
i've lost it now let me just go back
down
um yeah it says we could
uh finance the vehicles
to the uh company who gets the
um whoever it is who ends up with it
uh are we legally allowed to do that as
a council
be basically a finance company
you might have my help with this well no
the the short answer is
i'm not sure if it can be a finance
company but but certainly we're legally
allowed to do this arrangement
yes i mean it's it's um frequently done
uh across other brother waste contracts
and certainly it's nothing um
particularly new in terms of suggestion
but yes my understanding is
we are legally out soon okay thank you
thank you characteristic counselor smith
thank you
um what's been described to us uh
as a framework is very comprehensive and
i have no doubt that with the support
that has been described a good contract
will be
arrived at um i'll take one small issue
with you marcus you said we've got a
good service at the moment it's a great
service at the moment
so it really is a good service in fact
we frequently hear councillor williams
uh telling us uh giving us compliments
about the crews particularly in the last
year
and and how well they that they've done
we uh we've admired the commitment of
them
they've been they've been very
responsive
under and the current contract is one
that has got the overwhelming support of
our residents and has
served the district so so so very well
so with within the framework that you've
got
how do you try and match
those sort of factors the the commitment
of the crews the dedication of the staff
the support that that we need of our
residents
thank you
if i can um take you down it's within
the quality
evaluation criteria so in many ways
there's the method
delivery statements within there so you
would be asking how they
apologize how they do actually manage
their staff and sort of culture they
have
so we can score against that i mean what
i would also
there is undeniably always uh achieving
problems when a new contract starts
um but i think you know it's as much um
i'll take some credit here
that the culture of the council that
they work with as much as the culture of
the contractor
so um we equally have a good reputation
i i understand
um from speaking to another couple of
contractors that were a council they
want to work with
as we have a a of of wishing to work in
in true partnership and that is part of
the the specification
but again they say you know you
you you tease this out within the
equality assessment and within the
within the presentations and the
negotiation period
thank you councillor belton
thank you um just just one small point
and i agree that we do have a fantastic
service and
and the vast the vast amount of things
we ever see from the public is praise so
that's that's great
um one area i think we we can look at
within the tender and i won't go into
the specifics obviously from the exempt
but
within that 40 um quality is looking
at the environmental impact the carbon
neutrality thing
with the carbon neutral target that the
council have i think this is a perfect
opportunity to make sure anyone that we
partner with on such a big project
is on the same page as us in terms of
future goals and that that we're looking
to really maximize
those carbon savings and for the for the
one
of the sort of the environmental
services
thanks thank you council belton i'm sure
that's noted
council award thank you chairman um it's
just on the uh
the tendering uh i just wondered what
impact the remnants of eu law
would have i'm not sure if those parts
have actually been repealed by
parliament
because uh that you're shaking your head
so
um i take it that's the case that they
haven't been repealed at all and we
still have to take notice
yes we do yeah i think i think i mean i
mentioned this the the slight change
uh it's now called the fine finder
tender service that we use
rather than the old sort of service that
he had to publish upon so
um but the actual law itself and the
framework behind it
stayed fundamentally the same thank you
very much
yeah i can't see any more blue hands
just before i go to the
vote um can i just remind
members that uh waste collection over
the last
year alone has gone up by 35
due to people working from home uh
clearing out their old rubbish
or just generally generating more stuff
to collect
um and our collectors have dealt with
that
quietly they just got on with the job a
week or so after christmas we were aware
that there was about a third of the
workforce that was suffering or needed
to isolate
through the effects of hobie
all that happened with us is we ran one
day behind
on collecting one bin collection that
was against the background of
other councils still catching up until
the middle of january
but no on the 4th of january we were
back to normal
with minor disruption despite there
being a third
of the staff off and needing to be off
so that is a real tribute to those guys
under good management that got on with
the job
i want to emphasize the point that
councillor smith said
it isn't just a good service we provide
our residents it's a brilliant service
it's thorough it complies
and it's an award-winning service it's
nationally acclaimed
but of course people take it for granted
because if my bin doesn't get collected
one week
all of a sudden because i've been so
used to it being perfect
i think something horrendous must have
gone wrong but the reality is
it's a missed bin for good reason
and actually when you phone up and i've
had recent experience because my bin was
missed a few weeks ago
they were on the case within a day and
it was collected
it is a superb service
but if you look at the changes other
authorities are having to make
ours will still be a superb service
and that is the comparison that we need
to remember as we look around so
it's indeed a thorough report no stone
has been left unturned
thank you to members who contributed to
that report thank you to marcus for the
work that you've done
and thank you to councillor williams for
under your stewardship
uh you've led the environment team where
this particular project
is concerned so thank you very much
indeed once again to
to everyone now turning to the
recommendations
there are five set out in parallel 1.1
to 1.5
and i will read them uh number one
to agree a three-month extension to the
existing waste collection and street
cleansing contracts
to the end of july 2022 to allow
sufficient time for a procurement
process to be undertaken
number two to approve a budget of twenty
thousand pounds to appoint external
legal advisers
to provide advice on contract strategy
and preparation of legal documentation
item three to note the key terms to be
included in the tender of the waste
collection and street cleansing contract
as set out in this report
and note the timetable for the tendering
process
number four to note the proposed
procurement route
of competitive procedure with
negotiation
and the tender evaluation based on 60
price
40 quality scoring criteria
and the use of the evaluation criteria
set out
in exempt appendix 2.
and number 5 to note that the street
cleansing service
will be included within any waste
collection service contract
so i take you first of all members if i
may to
numbers three four and five because
those are items for noting
can i take it members that those items
are noted please
noted noted
thank you very much now moving to uh
recommendations one and two uh i wonder
whether
i can assume your agreement unless you
click on the raised hand icon
that we can take those both together
please that seems to make sense but uh
signal on the blue hand if you wish to
deal with them separately
and i can't see anyone signifying so we
take them together
and also now if members
anyone would like a recorded vote uh
please begin to
click on the right hand icon
raised hand icon
no i can't see anyone so we will take
those two recommendations
um i assume that everyone is able to use
the electronic hand
uh if not please unmute yourself and
slate
otherwise but finding that we will look
for
the race hand icon so all those in favor
of the recommendations set out please
please click on the raised and icon
i think that's unanimous sonia but you
will no doubt check for me
that is unanimous chairman thank you
thank you very much indeed uh members
and you can
uh raise your oak and you can lower your
uh blue hand
and uh there's really no point in
considering other uh
people voting against or abstaining is
there so uh so we're there
um so on that members concludes
the business for this evening's meeting
uh
thank you very much again for attending
and i now declare the meeting closed
at 8 23 or they're about
8 22. thank you very much indeed members
have a good evening thank you chairman
good night okay so good night hi
everybody
thank you everybody
thank you sonya